"Країна в смартфоні". Аби громадяни забули,
як виглядають чиновники.
Цей амбітний проект хоче реалізувати президент
Володимир Зеленський і його діджітал-команда.
Сьогодні ми говоримо про це з радником президента Михайлом Федоровим.
Доброго дня!
Взагалі-то чинний уряд вважає, що"країна в смартфоні"вже існує.
Виходить, ви нічого нового не створюєте?
Зараз я Вам покажу, на якому етапі перебуває "держава в смартфоні".
Насправдібазовіпроцеси заклали ще чотири роки тому,
але нефундаментальні та несистемні.
Ось, погляньте. Приміром, сайт кабінету міністрів,
де можна отримати державні е-послуги. Ось - знизу.
Якщо нам потрібна певна довідка, то нас відсилають на інший ресурс,
на якому незрозуміло, де цю довідку отримати.
Наразі існує майже 100 е-послуг, якими дуже важко скористатися.
Це пов’язано і з загальною архітектурою усього електронного уряду,
і з візуальною частиною user experience, також
багато у чому це пов’язано з тими нормами
кібербезпеки, що їх закладали ще в 70-их роках.
Ви кажете, що це застаріле. А чи знаєте ви, скільки
людей цим скористалося? Попит на це є?
Попит є, але поки цією послугою користується лише невелика кількість людей.
Існує дві проблеми. Перша - це цифрова ідентифікація.
В нас, як в 90-х роках, діють норми, де підпис повинен бути
на захищеному носії і багато хто користується флешками.
Приміром, видаєтьсяID-паспорт, на якому теж може бути електроннийID-підпис.
Але, його там наразі немає, тож коли через кілька місяців з’явиться можливість
записувати та використовувати цифровий підпис наID-картку,
то три мільйони людей, які картку вже отримали,
повинні будуть піти та наново все оформити, щоб
записати і використовувати е-підпис наID-картці.
Тож один з наших пріоритетних напрямків роботи на 2019 рік -
це вирішити питання цифрової ідентифікації.
Ми хочемо, аби наID-карткахбув електронний підпис,
щоб його можна було використовувати і за допомогою
спеціального кардрідера, і з авторизацією в смартфоні.
Смарт-ID, щоб було все в смартфоні. І, звичайно, розвитокMobile ID.
Яким буде ступень захисту?
Питання кібербезпеки наразі на аудиті.
За перші три тижні роботи ми ініціювали багато процесів.
Але, звичайно, поки не вирішили питання кібербезпеки,
на вирішення якого не вистачило попередніх 28-ми років.
За якими показниками проводиться аудит?
Як мінімум ми не до кінця розуміємо, де лежать сервери усіх держреєстрів.
Не розуміємо, які реєстри, в кого на балансі, де та хто їх розробляв.
Не існує єдиного документа, в якому можна
подивитися, де ж ці реєстри зберігаються.
А де вони мають зберігатися?
Кожна держава, певна річ, приховує, де її реєстри.
Це має бути окреме захищене місце.
Але точно це не якийсь системний блок, який стоїть
під столом у чиновника, який в незрозуміло якому кабінеті сидить.
Ви зачепили тему держреєстрів. Чи подобається вам,
як вони працюють і як захищені?
І що робити з фактами шахрайства та рейдерства?
Так, рейдерство в держреєстрах – це одне з перших питань,
які ініціювала і почала вирішувати адміністрація президента.
АП ініціювала запровадження в Державному підприємстві
"Національні інформаційні системи" - НАІС - позиції заступника з цифровізації.
Зараз готується кілька рішень, які дозволять покласти край рейдерству.
Йдеться про тактичні рішення, а стратегічні можна
буде ухвалювати після повноцінного аудиту.
Ви можете сказати, щосьогодні держреєстрибільш захищені,
ніж, скажімо, два місяці тому?
Наразі ні. Але, черезодин-два тижні вони матимуть вже кращий захист.
Все залежить від активних дій в мінюсті.
Ви ж розумієте, що реєстри - це одне з головних джерел заробітку і корупції.
Тому туди швидко ніхто нікого пускати не хоче.
А чи пустять?
В них немає виходу. По-перше, незабаром вибори,
тож зміняться і коаліція, і склад міністерств
І я впевнений, що туди зайдуть нормальні, порядні люди.
Щодо держреєстру та земельних кадастрів.
Чи можете ви сказати людям, що ви відкриєте ці дані для усіх,
а не лише для чиновників, котрі цю інформацію тримають закритою?
З приводу держреєстру землі,наскільки язнаю,
там вже вжили деякихзаходів щодо відкриття кадастрів.
Але процес завжди гальмується регуляторно:
документ лежить на підпис у міністра, а він просто не підписує.
Ось, маємо онлайн-кабінет забудовника, через який він отримує різні довідки.
Тобто вже реалізовані технічні рішення і частину ліцензій
забудовник може отримати в режимі онлайн, без участі чиновника.
Чи можуть люди побачити, що це забудовник,
які дозволи він має? Ця інформація буде відкритою?
Звичайно. Взагалі відкриття даних - одне з головних питань,
бо частину даних монополізували і продають через окремі компанії.
Законопроект про відкриті дані давно готовий,
але його ніяк не можуть проголосувати.
Він лежить в ВР вже кілька років, але його десь постійно гублять.
Тому нашою ініціативою було внестив партійний список
"Слуги народу" якомога більше IT-шників.
При чому, з різних галузей і тих, хто безпосередньо
не був пов’язаний з нашою командою.
Щоб  мати баланс думок з технічних питань і критичний погляд.
Верховна Рада та чинні народні депутати, можливо, хочуть заробити…
Чому ви не захочете заробити?
В нас інші цінності. Ми хочемо відкрити понад 70 послуг,
хочемо зробити аудит реєстрів, хочемо вирішити питання
з е-ідентифікацією, порушити питання з е-резидентством в Україні.
Для будь-якої людини на планеті це є нагодою стати
електронним громадянином України, зареєструвати
тут свою компанію, сплачувати податки,
користатися іншими е-послугами.
Було б ідеально, якби ми сфокусувалися на фрілансерах
з усього світу і надали можливість айтішникам
реєструвати тут ФОПИ або інші форми компаній, створювати тут мікрокоманди.
Ми можемо запровадити спеціальні пільги для тих,
хто інвестуватиме гроші в нашу країну.
За даними уряду "країна в смартфоні"надає 120 послуг.
Ви плануєте додати ще 70
Вивчався попит?
Звичайно вивчався і це дуже цікаво.
Чому ми постійно говоримо про молодих матусь?
Тому що вони найактивніші. Я не кажу про бізнес,
бо бізнес - питання номер один.
Але молоді матусі теж велика аудиторія.
Бо коли народжується дитина, тобі не треба ходити
по десяти-одинадцяти державних компаніях, бо немає ні сил, ні енергії.
А тут ти можеш прямо з пологового будинку зареєструвати свою дитину,
податися на отримання соціальних виплат для дитини.
Ось, зараз готується законопроект Е-малятко.
Для пенсіонерокта пенсіонерів є щось у "країні в смартфоні"?
Те, що зараз передбачає соцзахист: призначення житлових субсидій, пенсій.
Скажу чесно, я поки не дійшов до аналітики, щоб поглянути,
скільки пенсіонерів користуються цією послугою в онлайні.
Але точно можу сказати, що з огляду на дизайн, зручність,
тоі я на цьому сайті не зміг би отримати потрібну мені послугу.
Тому перше, що ми зробимо - створимо єдиний дизайн-код,
єдинуUX-систему, в якій будь-кому буде зручно.
Людина просто натискає на"так"чи"ні", обирає вік, галочкою відмічає.
Щоб була зручна система, в якій візуально зрозуміло,
наскільки швидко отримати послугу, щоб не заповнювати якісь форми.
Незабаром ми оприлюднемо дані, скільки людей користуються е-послугами.
Бо ще одна проблема - не існує жодної аналітики.
І це те, що ще треба будувати.
Для звичайного українця що таке "країна в смартфоні"
з огляду на його повсякденні потреби?
Це можливість виключити будь-який фізичний контакт з державою.
Якщо тебе зупинила поліція на машині, ти показав свій додаток або сказав код.
Тобі не потрібно показувати права.
Щонайменше для мене це проблема, бо я постійно забуваю удома гаманець з правами.
І мене це напружує. Навіщо носити з собою шматок пластику?
Для мене, як для чоловіка з машиною, це вже була б "країна в смартфоні".
Або, наприклад, відкрити рахунок в банку.
І таких питань багато аж до продажу нерухомості в форматі
онлайн через блокчейн, використовуючи смарт-контракт.
Якщо взяти Запоріжжя, де ви народилися,
як там зміниться життя, якщо запрацює "країна в смартфоні",
якщо ця "країна в смартфоні" дійде до регіонів, котрі будуть не протидіяти,
а брати і використовувати нові розробки?
В Запоріжжя наразі дуже не вистачає нового житла,
а ми розуміємо, наскільки це корумпована галузь,
і наскільки корупція гальмує її розвиток.
Тому онлайн-кабінет забудовника міг би дуже прискорити будівництво.
Також "велика корупція" ховається в галузі соціальних виплат.
За різними даними, до 30% соціальних виплат -
мільярди гривень на рік - витрачаються, тобто платяться людям, яких не існують.
І це питання роботи з реєстрами, питання персональної ідентифікації.
Я відкрию вам таємницю: в кожній ОДА ми плануємо
запровадити посаду заступника губернатора з питань цифровізації.
В нас, в жодній ОДА , імовірно, ще не запровадили електронний документообіг,
а ця людина може прийти і нарешті зробити це.
Як мінімум, створити чат-бота. Знов вам ексклюзив. Це губер-боти.
Губер?
Ми знаємо, що немає позиції губернатора.
Губер-бот. Це стьоб. Просто має бути модно.
Діджітал…це коли інструменти модні, подекуди смішні, тоді ними користуються.
"Країна в смартфоні" - це величезний проект і величезні ресурси.
На якому KPI, або на яких показниках ефективності ви його розраховували?
Для мене ключовий KPI, і я повішу його собі на стіну,
це те, скільки людей щотижня користуються е-послугами.
Бо про них можна багато класно розповідати, зробити їх супермега-чудовими,
але якщо ними не користуватимуться, то який з них зиск.
Я краще зроблю 10 послуг, які будуть потрібні 30 млн. людей на рік,
ніж зроблю 1 200, якими будуть користуватися 3% населення.
При правильній аналітиці можна легко все розрахувати.
Ми розуміємо обсяг, грубо кажучи, ринку.
400 тисяч дітей народжується. 40 тисяч молодих матусь
минулого року отримали соціальні виплати, зареєструвавшись онлайн.
На рівні 10%. В нормальних розвинених країнах, навіть пострадянських, має бути десь 70%.
Ви хочете дізнатися скільки людей в майбутньому будуть користуватися "країною в смартфоні".
Але ви ж не знаєте, скільки взагалі громадян України?
Хороше запитання. Зараз готується перепис населення,
закуповуються планшети, буде тестовий перепис
Існують різні думки щодо того, як цей перепис провести.
І точно цей процес треба якось поєднати з отриманням електронної ідентифікації.
Щоб не вийшло так, що ми людей не зрозуміло як переписали,
а потім почали видавати їм електронні підписи.
Ми хочемо все це поєднати. Як? Поки не знаю.
Але з кожного напрямку, який ми обговорюємо, в нас є робочі групи,
до яких входять представники бізнесу, ГО,
різних відомств, які працюють над цими питаннями.
Е-перепис можливий?
Це було б ідеально.
Я так розумію, що існують приблизні розрахунки, що Україна може отримати.
А чи існують розрахунки, на чому Україна
в результаті цих е-реформ заощадить і скільки саме?
ФондUSAIDготує аналіз: скільки послуг, які вже існують
і яка на них економія. Це мільярди.
Лише на соцвиплатах йдеться про мільярди, які платяться невідомо кому.
Цифри люблять точність, тому ми оприлюднимо результати дослідження фондуUSAID.
Чи є черга бажаючих заробити на цьому проекті?
Усі такі приходять добрі-милі. Мовляв, як вам допомогти?
Бо вони розуміють, що ми ще глибоко не усвідомлюємо, як все влаштовано в держбюджеті.
Не розуміємо, де там ті гроші, які вони хочуть вкрасти.
А на цьому сайті, який ми до кінця року викотимо з нашою дорожньою картою,
що ми будемо робити, які результати, хто відповідальний,
обов’язково буде чат-бот, якому можна повідомити про підозри в корупції.
Вас особисто що саме надихає на "країну в смартфоні"?
Я взагалі-то сам про це думав. Мене дружина запитує, близькі.
Вони бачать, що в мене багато енергії працювати над цією темою.
Особисто для себе я знайшов мотивацію в тому,
що люблю запускати якісь великі цікаві проекти.
В професійному плані це для мене просто історичний момент.
Бо такої можливості для реалізації в мене ще не було і може більше не трапитися.
Реалістично… можете назвати три пункти, які ви точно виконаєте?
Ми почнемозі створення власне бренду "країна в смартфоні".
Він має бути найкращим в світі!
Ми зробимо е-ідентифікацію в смартфоні.
Точно переведемо 90% сервісів в онлайн.
Якщо я буду цим займатися, а життя воно таке непередбачуване,
то перші електроні вибори відбудуться вже через 5 років.
Е-вибори?
Е-вибори. Ми точно розуміємо, як їх зробити, і точно будемо до них рухатися.
Естонія до цього йшла 15-20 років. Поки в них онлайн голосує усього лише 40% країни.
Мені здається, що Україна могла б одразу перестрибнути на 50%.
Дуже дякую вам за інтерв’ю.